well I mean I think the the very
question clearly suggests that we we
obviously need to have one because there
are so much of common threads that bring
us all together as people and I cannot
think of any better institution than the
United Nations which is the single most
important institution which can actually
bring us together now unfortunately the
role of United Nations and its
effectiveness has been undermined in the
last few several decades and so we
obviously have to commit ourselves to
you and reform but if you look at the
role of international law in the human
context and outside the UN context its
role has not been completely negated if
you look at for example the significant
developments that have taken place in
the field of international trade law and
the acceptance of the WTO law and the
World Trade Organization as a single
important institution and the appellate
body of the World Trade Organization in
some ways passing judgments about the
decisions of sovereign countries so
sovereignity in some ways has been
indeed and successfully undermined when
it comes to WTO and international trade
law now where there is still resistance
as far as countries are concerned is
when it comes to for example issues
relating to international humanitarian
law international human rights law and
to some extent broader issues relating
to public international law so the point
here is that States I mean always look
at their personal at their interest and
when they're when that when the when
these interests are largely commercial
in nature in the context of trade law or
intellectual property law there is
little resistance on the part of the
states to subject themselves to a
international tribunal in the form of a
WTO appellate body and but when it comes
to human rights issues or other issues
which I just mentioned there is still
resistance so I think in the years to
come
states should become much
more confident about themselves about
their actions and should also be
responsible about their actions and
should be mindful of the fact that there
are these international institutions in
the form of the United Nations and the
bodies under the United Nations be the
International
all the bodies whether the dup World
Health Organization the Food and
Agriculture Organization the human in
the human rights field the Human Rights
Council there are a number of
international bodies already in
existence now we have to empower these
institutions better so that they are
more effective in the years to come
there is I don't see any reason for us
to in some ways reinvent the wheel we
just have to make the wheel work better
it actually worked pretty well because
we've not had a third world war you know
which would have been catastrophic for
the whole world and we have had number
of atrocities and violations and
problems that have taken place and
global challenges have to be met
globally for example the climate change
issue now increasingly climate change is
a problem which and global warming
cannot be solved by individual countries
acting alone and the we need legal and
regulatory policy environmental and a
number of other issues that need to be
brought together through a multilateral
process and only a UN type organization
under its umbrella can be effective for
this
you